Let’s talk about keeping the faith.
Celebrating births and marriages
mourning the dead
coming together to mark the holidays.
They've all been derailed.
Sacred sites and places of worship have been closed.
No big festivals,  no shared meals
no proper funerals.
Whether you're religious or not.
So how are people coping?
How do we maintain our spiritual
and cultural practices under lockdown?
And what can we all do to stay strong?
Some of us choose to navigate through life on our own.
But the vast majority of people turn to religion
for spiritual sustenance, direction and community.
Especially when times are hard.
And this pandemic is one of those times.
Over 85% of the world's population
considers religion very important in their lives.
And so when they cannot gather
as a result of the social restrictions of COVID-19
it feels like an incredible loss.
Governments around the world have banned religious
and spiritual gatherings to contain the pandemic.
And with good reason.
Probably the most notorious example
of what they’re trying to avoid is the story of Patient 31.
In early February a woman in South Korea
developed a fever and went to hospital.
She was tested for COVID-19
but before her results came back
she attended at least four church services.
She even went for a buffet lunch.
By the start of March more than 4,000 people
were infected — 60% of them were from her church.
Easy to see though how just one person
can become a super-spreader.
April is a big month for religious holidays
but this year things had to change.
Jews who would normally share meals
and prayers for Passover were forced to congregate online.
“I’m here to welcome all of you to our Zoom Pesach.”
Instead of celebrating mass
before tens of thousands of worshippers
in Saint Peter’s Square
Pope Francis livestreamed his Palm Sunday sermon.
Sikhs usually hold the festival Vaisakhi.
This year they did it at a safe distance.
There were other celebrations,  too, like Orthodox Easter
and a Hindu festival called Rama Navami.
And now Ramadan
a month of fasting considered holy
by 2 billion Muslims around the world.
People won't gather together for breaking of the fast
to pray in the evenings and they won’t gather together
when it comes to Eid, where people come together
to celebrate the end of the month of Ramadan.
We all plan to have a big Zoom Eid party
dress nice and have fun.
It’s going to be a little more different than usual
but I think we’ll still have a good time.
The faithful around the world
no matter what their religion
are having to adjust.
And congregations are getting creative.
Families are re-enacting rituals at home.
Many are taking advantage of technology.
Or tuning into more traditional channels.
Every Sunday now if you want to attend a mass
you just turn on your TV and that’s also good.
That said not everyone has found it easy to adapt.
My parents, they seem to be having a hard time.
One of the ways to cope with it is their faith
and just putting everything in God's hands but right now
you know, that’s been a struggle.
Others just can’t afford the tech.
Those groups that are least resourced may also be
the groups that most need religion.
And it goes beyond the spiritual.
Some people rely on their religious community
to make sure they get enough to eat.
They might provide economic benefit for people.
And they of course provide emotional
and psychological support.
And there’s probably no more difficult time
than losing someone.
The pandemic has forced
restrictions on funerals and burials
that defy our universal rituals of saying goodbye.
Some cultures are adapting traditional ceremonies.
This farewell to a prominent Maori leader
was broadcast on national television in New Zealand.
But for a lot of people saying goodbye from a distance
or online just isn’t enough.
As a family, being together with her would have helped us
grieve together for a moment as well
which helps you also acknowledge the enormity
of what’s happened.
It still feels like I’m going to have to wake up
tomorrow and ring people and tell them I got it wrong
and that she’s still alive.
All of this puts spiritual
and religious leaders in a tough spot.
Many want to provide comfort to their followers
but they’re also obliged to stop them
from coming together.
And that goes against centuries
of religious practices.
Historically I can't imagine any imam, any leader of a mosque
ever having a situation where they have to
close the doors of the mosque, which is supposed to be
a sanctuary at times of difficulty.
The vast majority of religious leaders and scholars
around the world are leading by example.
But some are breaking the rules.
Remember the story about Patient 31?
“Some local leaders have called for Shincheonji’s elders
to be investigated for possible homicide.”
Several church leaders are accused of
hiding the identities of their followers
from South Korean officials
trying to track down cases of COVID-19.
Other religious communities have ignored lockdowns too.
Large weddings by Hasidic Jews went ahead in New York.
Some Muslims in Malaysia kept going to Friday prayers.
Mega-churches in US states like Florida
and Louisiana were still packed.
Bless them, bless them. Put a holy boldness on them.
And it’s caused a backlash.
For example an Islamic group in India
held an event against police orders.
That led to a surge in anti-Muslim violence.
It’s a trying time for a lot of people.
None of us have ever lived through
anything like this before.
Closing more public spaces.
“Forcibly separated from loved ones.”
Around 100,000 people have died.
World powers that are armed for the world’s biggest wars
are now fighting for basic protective gear.
Lockdowns are already taking a toll on
our spiritual and mental well-being.
Everybody is having a lot of fear and panic, anxiety.
We shouldn't underemphasise the collateral impact
that COVID-19 social restrictions will have on
our mental health and on our psyche.
So in absence of a physical connection
people are coping the best they can.
Utilise technology because getting together and meeting
is really important especially in times like these.
It's not from outside. It's from here.
What you feel here.
Just keep believing, keep praying for the health workers
for those who are sick and for yourselves
who are sitting at home safe.
It’s in difficult times like this that people turn to their faith
and to each other for support.
It shows just how precious our sense of community really is.
“We don’t know when we’ll be back on
the Start Here set but not to worry.
We’re still going to be bringing you more episodes
any way we can.
In the meantime our website aljazeera.com
has all the latest on the coronavirus pandemic.
I’ll see you next week.”